hey guys i'm ryan right and i'm ryan
right so Jerry and I are gonna watch the
trailer today for we're gonna start off
with this movie called tusks
and I believe it's a Kevin Smith horror
comedy okay that's all I know about
it'll walrus you think so have you seen
Kevin you haven't seen red-state that's
pretty cool I've heard yeah I've heard
it's interesting yeah it definitely
doesn't play out like how you would
expect them to be like that to play out
okay so you're gonna say like it doesn't
play out like you expected Kevin yeah
just a bunch of sex banter the whole
yeah exactly
this is whether people talk about stuff
yeah no let's check this trailer out all
right
Jerzy go okay there's some disturbing
violence heavyweight said that yes he
did
to their cuts [ __ ] aren't you two hours
away American guys good evening
nice to meet her ease back could I
interest you in some team so what
happened after the boat sank
I was alone content something very Swift
and frightening moved by me come to me
thank you you're welcome
[Music]
there yes
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it looks like a really well-made movie
yeah I mean certainly not what I was
expecting
no it mean it looks like a film at a
horror movie that actually has like
characters in it like characters that
speak like people you know like it has a
sense of humor about it and stuff and
I'm drawn to that movie itself is kind
of like misery meets something this
whole trailer reminded me of the human
centipede for some reason no there's
that too and only because he's trying to
turn them into a walrus or something
right that's what it sounds like I get
some kind of sense for that some kind of
weird body
yeah I can't stand me out it doesn't
seem like it what's cool about it is
like it's kind of like a torture film
but it's not a torture film oh you don't
know that it could be a torture film
well could be a surgical torture film be
like you think he intentionally wants to
hurt him or is he trying to actually
like I feel like this guy has like this
weird philosophy oh yeah turn him into
something you know yeah but I mean even
so it might not be entirely like I just
want to hurt you but it's still going to
be painful oh yeah surgically yeah yeah
but I mean like it's not it doesn't seem
to me like the villain is a guy who's
like I just want to hurt people or some
[ __ ] you know does anyway he gets a high
off of that but I'm sure they'll be
tortured [ __ ] in that yeah it's always
the reasoning behind its work yeah
there's torture for fun or torture for
some grander purpose it seems like it'll
be at least something of an
uncomfortable experience for Justin long
and his mustache what animal would you
want to turn into I probably want to be
a I probably want to be a that's what
came out of my mouth my subconscious
talking I was like
thing just sit I guess I want to be a
penguin alright people like penguins you
know cuz I kind of got a belly and Hagan
listen slime in the ice for their belly
yeah you know I like the way they walk
if you go to paint sorry documentary
belly
hey if you wiped out penguins I'm sure
the ecosystem will be affected in more
ways than you could imagine
no I'm sure I'm sure I'm just saying
they're not like without scary and
they're kind of they walk funny and
people who look like penguins get made
fun of yeah well I guess mm-hmm it's
like that thing I just saw it said like
I can't remember her now it was wasps or
mosquitoes or something but like without
those we wouldn't have fig you lie about
one thing you never know
don't walruses have the biggest penises
out of all the animals I don't think
that's true no no no assume an elephant
has a bigger penis well maybe it depends
on cuz I cuz this is just a conversation
that comes up periodically in life but I
think it's there are different ways of
measuring that it's like the the size to
body mass ratio or whatever it's like
that is how much for mine I go to the
gym and they do it for me well you know
it's like how big is it compared to how
big the rest of you is so like something
that looks relatively big could be on a
massive creature and on that creature it
might not look so big makes sense makes
sense can you guys tell us which animal
has the biggest penis I'm too lazy to
type it I don't Google myself yeah and
you're doing like you'll see whales that
like ones they're like nine feet long
but mm-hmm
but I don't know how that if you follow
her Instagram you can see a horse peen
why I got the footage why would you get
that footage I was just recording a
horse and then this [ __ ] whipped down I
was like that's a huge [ __ ] and they
just started pissing and I got it on
camera why did you do that
because I was recording a horse what
were you recording a horse [ __ ] horse
often I see a horse you I was up in up
north in Lincoln's Marin County San
Francisco area there's a lot of horses
there okay recording the horse well I
don't know no they don't were sleek here
we're meeting my privacy no you can
record horses any horses
justic and beautiful animals but but you
know like what it decides to unleash the
full extent of its penis and take a pure
sign up and get it on camera
I probably would not get this kind of
get no I think you might have a change
of heart in the moment I would probably
put the camera down and then like stare
wide-eyed Lee at it yeah but instead of
just keep you answer yourself you could
share that for everyone why are you sure
oh do you need a channel you can
subscribe I'm sorry and that's against
of your horse PE video I know how much
it means to you that's okay since it got
a lot of likes on Instagram I thought
like wow that's pretty cool and here you
come my best friend you're like I don't
really care about the horse bean video I
just do this I don't just say that in
caravans I'd rather strange it's like
one of these things is not like any
other video you've ever put and it's the
horse pee well I see no mix it up let's
roll that footage that's the horse is
huge long I don't know if there's a lot
of be on YouTube that's big I got it on
camera
oh is this legal oh sure I don't know
does it count as some kind of bestiality
porn if you're shy I have no idea
thank you guys for everything why don't
we do some shout outs real fast let's
get that out of the way let's just get
it out of the way people are gonna wait
for their name to be said they're gonna
get mad that name was a Saturday be like
did I totally asked you yesterday why
the [ __ ] didn't give me a shout-out so
yeah
24 420 Veronica is so beautiful trust me
this guy knows that he does or you do me
oh yeah I'm this guy alright Veronica is
beautiful oh my god you are so lucky guy
bro I know and now shout out please okay
okay 24-hour twenty shout out to you my
friend hey you complimented the right
girl on the channel okay right right
am i ending at something yes because I
took off my hat I took off my hat I want
a hint but I want to make anything
confirmed or clear okay yeah it's pretty
[ __ ] obvious perhaps the more you
talk about what the matter and what
you're clarifying it it will just become
lesson
yeah well yeah twenty four twenty twenty
four twenty thanks
zombies snowman zombies snowman shout
out bro
zombie snowman that is a cool name my
friend yeah it's a whimsical image I
like this I feel like there should be
like a comic strip about it yeah man
he's like a snowman who gets bitten by a
zombie and then turns into a zombie
snowman yeah this goes right yeah
there's snowman and the only way to kill
him is for spring to come yeah exactly
so the humans have to wait yeah it was
like one zombie they can't take it out
for some reason it's like they're not
very strong so there's so kind of
indoors I would like to see that a movie
about a zombie that is moves incredibly
slow but for some reasons taking out an
entire city do you mean just just single
bomb only ones on and yeah they just
kill them everyone just sees them and
they run the [ __ ] I want a big gun scene
where they just shoot him with all kinds
of guns but they never hit him in the
head and then pretty soon he like he's
just a head rolling around town trying
to fight yeah yeah that's a zero Otto
it's your bio piss on the zombies
snowman's biotech right there hey we
came out with your story
the svenska noir Donna I want shots or
answers from what was that I was like
slightly John Claude Van Damme I just
did or something yeah I'm going to kick
and Bisons ass but he does the worst
American accent yeah yeah and I do the
worst jean-claude Van Damme in Russian
at least you're all doing bad
impressions oh yes
point proven you know you use gray
svenska no Donna you're gonna get a
shout-out I wonder what their name is or
you know for evil country you think they
originate from a mouth Swedish or
Russian
you're like Swedish or Norwegian
interesting I don't know anything about
Norwegian girls or guys mmm cool so that
must mean they're really into pot and
low sex maybe I mean if it offends the
channel it's safe to assume that people
from Europe are watching us that's
probably what they like to do or at
least like dance music yeah we're not
really a dance channel
I don't know oh okay you know you
provided me with nothing to give you a
shout out on besides your name Scott son
Scott could be German no I said yeah I'm
pretty sure you don't know that no
Spencer is not a very German no could be
a Nazi no I mean not I'm sure they were
never one of you owes me 100 Nazi scalps
and I want my scalps I don't know if
Russian uses months very much
you could be Russia Sweden or Norwegian
or Scandinavian here's what I know about
Russian people fun fact
they did a study statistics say that
Russian porn in Russia the most searched
pornography in Russia is actually
Russian girls Wow Oh in America I never
type in American girl
oh you mean they specifically look for
them yeah well I guess because you don't
need to do that here like here it's like
I imagine if you're googling porn or
whatever you don't have to specify
American because probably the results
will first and foremost be American or
maybe there'll be you know and then
you'll inevitably come across somebody
who's like British or Russian or
something I don't think it's that hard
in America to find American ports but
I'm saying it Russia they don't like
they have to type it in to you and they
still type in Russian point yeah I don't
know maybe there's an abundance of
American power to cut through or perhaps
they only want those results
specifically they're like we want to
weed out everything we were going to
take over the pornography I mean it
would be good for probably there would
be one time I did webcam with Russian
girl do you want to come baby that's
information I didn't necessarily yeah
with best thing to do is see after you
fool around with video cam with a girl
what you want to do is after you you
know finish your business you don't want
to stay on there so what I do I just
close the page because they're gonna try
to talk to you and get money that's
[ __ ] anything I do say thank you I had
a great time
and that's [ __ ] up it's like you gotta
have a little bedside manner she's a
[ __ ] [ __ ] with matter she's trying
to support herself most likely if she
probably works for some guy that over
your elation it makes for a fun banter
well we're from Russia - porn - cam
girls
what else would you really expect yeah
welcome to the real rejects